you know because we we like to talk
about the police
and you know with the big movement to
abolish police this is why i'm saying
right now i've i've i've been on the
abolish the police train for a little
bit mostly talking to michael malus and
it has a lot to do with watching what
happened with the lockdowns how many
cops not all of them you know nypd i
think a lot of people on the right
had had a moment they went through
something watching those videos yeah but
they're going right back to
back the blue you know there's a period
where we saw people on the right
throwing police the thin blue line flag
on the ground and stomping on it because
the cops were now turning on them but
you look at what's happening in
australia and who's enforcing it it's
all these metro cops and they're they're
they're macing little girls it is some
of the most insane for their power yeah
for
they're busting down doors and taking
people out of their homes they're
shutting down churches in new york city
they shut down churches you i'm telling
you right now you've got you've got a
slight opportunity or you had it's
probably gone when the left kept saying
defund and abolish if every conservative
said you got it
then you would avoid what's coming next
i mean the issue there is you have a
psychological
uh difference of a viewpoint when it
comes to it so the right is one of the
uh leading planks of the right is is
wanting an ordered society right so this
idea of being conservative means that
you want that traditional ordered
society and so rule of law and the
enforcement mechanism the forcing
function for rule of law would be a
lawful and
uh dignified police service of course
and that's the idea versus what is that
what's happening and that's not what's
happening right but what i'm saying is
is you to get a conservative to kind of
go wholeheartedly and join hands with
like a blm member on that you it would
take a lot of conversation and a lot of
looking at issues like what you're
talking about by the way and getting
them to actually sit down and say wait a
minute perhaps there were and i actually
had
uh nico house who's a
blm guy he's like a man of left but he's
someone that i've become friends with
and some that i talked to and one thing
that he always says is jack i i'm not
against the rule of law what i'm against
is corruption right and aren't you
against corruption i said well yeah of
course i'm against corruption well then
maybe we're not as in disagreement as it
seems yeah the enforcement mechanism i
don't think is the problem i think the
the problem is
these leaders who have newfound powers
that no one is stopping absolutely i
agree with you that the police should
not be enforcing bad laws plus by the
way
when you demonize the police when you
demonize them
cops leave and scrubs come here
saying i am ordering all churches to
shut and and so people thanks and it
takes courage people to say i'm just not
listening to that now step by step
cops
the cops are playing their role i agree
with you but step one is when the when
the mayor says as of today no church is
allowed to be open you know you need
priests and and ministers and
parishioners to say
this is an excuse
we hear all the time
right now there's a mandate in new york
city if you are if you are disabled sick
or unable to get the vaccine or for a
religious reason it is not the police
stopping you it is the mom and pop
restaurants and bakery saying f you get
out of my store i don't care
i was told to do it so i will if all of
these people in new york said i will not
abide by illegal activities because
violating discriminating at someone on
the base of a disability is a violation
of new york city state and federal
health and non-discrimination laws
they'll do it anyway because they don't
care they're feckless spineless pathetic
losers they all do it and each and every
one of these police officers has a
choice they can be a villain
when when you want to be a henchman to
the villain by all means that's your
choice no one forces these people to be
henchmen but if the cops want to come
out and say yeah i don't care if it's
unconstitutional i don't care if it
violates my oath of the constitution i'm
going to beat that old lady so she can't
go to church it's not cuomo who did it
it's that individual police officers i
agree with you and they're and they're
doing it to restaurants they're doing it
to salons they're letting prisoners go
and locking up
small business owners this is
tyranny exactly and you see what's
happening in australia
we are we are we are a few months behind
where they've been now we have a
constitution which does provide us some
shielding in this but if police officers
have already been willing to arrest and
fine and and and uh block people from
going to church
it's the first amendment so it is the
role of don't care it is the role of
individuals
individual police officers and
individual
ministers
uh priests uh parish priests and
individuals or restaurant owners and and
bar owners it is the role of the
individual to say i am not following
this when you say abolish the police we
are talking about institutions and i
would argue that the institution is not
the thing at flaw right now so i i
disagree with the abolish the police
movement because we are talking about
institutional flaws you're absolutely
right if there is a cop who was told by
the sergeant hey you got to go to arrest
that person because they're trying to
get into the bar and they do it every
time well well then and that's a huge
problem absolutely and then enough cops
are eventually going to say i'm not
doing but teachers are already quitting
their jobs yeah i'm not following that
as jack just mentioned it it's an
individual problem the cops who won't do
it quit and we've seen that and i've got
an email after email and it's and it's
right now and
what do we see in seattle we saw the
cops apologizing to antifa as they
arrested the victim of anti-violence
crazy i can sum all this up for anyone
who who hasn't um you've gotten there
yet get out of cities
just get get out of cities just don't be
there right i i was joking with uh
michael knowles that he had that you
know reasons to vote for democrats book
and it's all blank on the inside
and that uh i was like i should take a
page out of your book and do a get out
of cities book and then just have one
page get out of cities the next page
just don't be there get out of it don't
be there and then you know 300 pages of
that which you know survival guide for
this yeah survival don't don't be there
and i have people say what do what
exactly do you mean by that jack and
they don't drill down and you know kind
of get into it i said get out of cities
but we do have institutional problems um
these institutions are we used to have
great
they're absolutely broken where is the
aclu
right
where is the that that was an
institution where is i would argue as
well where is the catholic church to say
sorry we're not closing our doors i
think the problem is
there are institutional failures we're
in a pandemic whatever you think about
the kovid whatever but we're in
officially a pandemic i think so we're
acting like habeas corpus is suspended
like spanish flu time like martial law
like we're basically under martial law
right now i don't think they've
officially declared it but that's how it
and we've suspended habeas corpus before
in this country
and and it didn't go very well like
lincoln did it during and people would
say well we won right but but we'll
disappoint
[Music]
when you have eugene dubs when you when
you have small businesses locked up
japanese in world war ii world war ii
small business owners being arrested
while prisoners are being freed and far
left to swing around causing billions in
damages in big and small cities across
this country it's not a suspension of
habeas corpus it's a narco tyranny and
the police are more than happy i will
tell you this
we we we already see the stories of the
sheriff in minnesota who arrested that
woman because she had a cafe and she
refused to shut down
if you purchase a weapon as is your
second amendment right to protect
yourself as riots are going on i
guarantee you these police will go to
your house and they will arrest you you
mean like kyle rittenhouse absolutely if
you are concerned that a 70 year old man
was bashed over that with a rock and
left bleeding on the ground which
happened in kenosha and you say i'm
scared for my community and then someone
comes to says how would you you're a
young man working at the ymca how would
you like to help protect our business as
you say okay and then when a man chases
you trying to steal your gun you flee
and then when someone else fires a gun
at you from behind you turn and when
that man reaches for your gun you fire
in defense they will lock you up
they will go to your house in wisconsin
black lives matter and when you brandish
a firearm to show that you're acting in
defense of your home the police will go
into your house and arrest you and black
lives matter will celebrate it they did
when black lives matter went to a house
in in milwaukee and set fire to it
because they thought two girls were
kidnapped there and they weren't
this is why a guy in his house sees the
same group and it was the same group
same activists and thinks i better
you know let them know i'm armed now he
shouldn't have pointed the weapon at
them that i can i can say but black
lives matter they were the ones who were
complaining about the cops but when the
cops showed up they celebrated it and
the cops didn't stop the writers what
did i say a year before this when we
were when we were still living in
philadelphia
and we were looking at the riots i said
i tell you this there will come a time
when the rioters when the mob when the
cultists the fascists whatever come to
your house and are protesting and the
police will show because of a
disturbance in the neighborhood and
they'll look at each other and say
what's easier arresting the guy in the
house or dealing with a riot just the
rest of the guy in the house and they've
done it
so
yeah keeping the peace they don't care
about your rights so i look at right now
when we see a lot of these cops quitting
after the defund the police stuff i tell
you this man the videos we see now like
the one in seattle auntie fuzz is
chasing a guy he's backing up and he's
saying get away from me and the cops
come and arrest him and then say i'm so
sorry ma'am would you mind and to antifa
i think extremists
i think though
to only blame cops and to single out
cops solely right is is
maybe a little bit you know limiting in
terms of how you're looking at it right
we are looking at in our cities
a symptom a symptom of a broader
societal collapse of moral values of
national institutions well i'm not just
one identity no i don't think you are
but i think a lot i think there are a
lot of people are who do that um and
i think that
a lot of what we're what we're seeing
now is the collapse of this very a lot
of this started in the 60s you can argue
it went back further but
when it really comes down to it if we do
not have a national shared vision of
what our morals are what our our
national identity is what does it mean
to be american when we are starting to
destabilize these societies like these
groups like auntie i just wrote a whole
book about antifa but and i pointed out
their their role is not like they have
their stated role but then they have
their actual in practice role they
destabilize systems right we saw this in
weimar germany where was the that was
the original institution of antifa right
they were a red front group the idea was
destabilize the country and then
somebody sweeps in and then someone
takes power thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you